I should probably get started so talking
a lot about how publishing tonight is
think about selection and different
models of selection selection sweeps and
so on
after that I now want to move into more
how do people try to detect selection in
in data and so I got out start by
motivated it with this it's gonna have
to run it starts where I supposed to
start yeah so okay there's two reasons
why people interested in detecting
selection and relating natural selection
and models of natural selection to data
but the one the first one is so what you
might immediately think of that you're
interested in where has step in natural
selection trying to understand processes
of the adaptation and natural species
and so on and the other one is that
there has been become controversy in the
field about how important is natural
selection so initially much discussed
about natural selection in in humans and
all populations will concentrate on the
factors on how much natural selection is
actually that was the big question and
that's questioning they expect to in
fact before that but what's really came
to the forefront with multiple mores
1969 paper where he proposed what she
called a neutral theory that if you look
at most differences between species and
within species the genetic variation
there between and within species that
that is really caused by genetic drifts
new mutations entering and then genetic
drift acting on them and not explained
by natural selection and that point in
time what people had of data was of
course very limited and think the view
for many people was that when you see
some differences between species is
because it's adaptive it's because
there's a reason why there's a
difference natural selection has favored
that and more took more than king who
theoretical blazoned is
came in a queue it's not it's completely
neutral there's no reason why you have
those differences except the random
facts are processes of mutation and
genetic drift
okay so much of the for the next twenty
thirty years much research was really
focuses on trying to test that
hypothesis and many of the ways of
detecting selection was developed in
that context and they were called
they're called tests of neutrality so
you simply formulate the problem as
there's no hypothesis that that there's
no selection and you're trying to see if
you can reject that null hypothesis and
the test aiming of that in to do that
they're called tests of neutrality so
focusing on this question of well how
important this natural selection before
get more in-depth for the test of
neutrality perhaps one of the most
important papers for that question was
this a paper by we gonna Anna Quattro
from 1992 where the they showed that if
you look at recombination rates so this
coefficient of exchange that's a mixture
of recombination rate and then
nucleotide diversity so a measure of
homogenate variability does you find a
positive correlation hi is the average
number pairwise differences so the
recover come measure that published in
genesis used to measure how much Teaneck
variability does which is one way to
think about how is calculating this you
take all pairs of sequences probably the
number of differences between them and
then a virtual comparisons everstyle or
pairwise differences sometimes it's also
called nucleotide diversity up high and
so you saw that you see this bit there
observing this positive correlation
which has been going in stock is a
different part of the genome in the
genome so if you look at different parts
of the genome the different
recombination rates in different part of
the t gnome so you could take you know
this part of the genome and this part of
the genome this part of the genome and
if you do that and then plot what is the
recombination rate and that part of the
genome and what's the nucleotide
traversed in that product you know
you'll find this positive correlation
that's in schloss tin history I think I
do remember x-chromosome okay so it's a
very famous plot this one for me a
nature paper that some know better than
all the skinny so thanks for that and so
this is a pattern that's been confirmed
in many other species who see the same
thing in humans it's not as pronounced
as this was for southla fruit flies but
you also see it in humans and one of the
part of the arguments about this was
then early arguments about this was well
this is exactly what we expect from the
Selective suite models because the
region that's been affected by snakes is
sweet by this process of an adaptive
mutation increasing in frequency in the
population that breeds it affected by
that is to turn by the recombination
rate if there's not a recombination mini
mutation will escape the selective sweep
that I've Arabic region will be affected
if there's no recombination of low
recombination rates at very last region
in the genome will be affected okay so
if they're lots of selected sweets you
would predict a positive correlation
like this and this initially was taking
to be evidence of selective sweeps in
the genome so one the last class of
model on selection I'm going to talk
about is an alternative hypothesis that
was proposed by Brian Charles for health
and colleagues and what he was saying is
well you couldn't imagine just having
lots of negative selection and it can
actually generate a similar pattern and
it's occurs if patients are negative
selected but they're not so negative
selected that they immediately weeded
out then negative selected but they can
still segregate by genetic drift that
could still increase in frequency and
segregate in the population the effect
of that well they fake their will affect
many provinces of genetic data but one
effect is that it will reduce the amount
of variability to simply because of the
selection acting against these different
classes of chromosomes that have
different number of deleterious
mutations and in that one paper a very
civil approximation was developed that
show that if you have a mutation rate
new to what still a terrorist mutation
and each of them has a selection
coefficient s and dominance coefficient
H you get this civil relationship you
can describe the gravity
our ability as a civil change on the
effective population size so if this is
an without right this kind of background
selection and you x take the exponent of
this and multiply with that then you get
a new effective population size to
describe the reduction in variability or
you can think of it as taking the
average number of pairwise differences
probably fall on the selection divided
by what it would be without selection
approximately proportional to this this
function here okay so that's that's good
question say any empirical evidence in
favor of the neutral their hypothesis I
mean the you know number of early
observations that seem to be in
accordance with that that people were
invoking were for example that you have
about how when we compare different
species you have about constant rate of
mutation and different lineages so
mutation occur at about accumulate on
different things in different species at
about a constant rate so that's
something you would predict from a news
report now so many selection models that
will predict the same thing but that was
some of the early evidence that was used
to say okay this is compatible with
neutrality but most of the time the way
people have formulated the question is
can we reject it to be not neutral so
the neutral model has been a null
hypothesis and I think these days this
is sort of a historical perspective
these days I don't think many people are
really interested in well the neutral
hypothesis is true or not
we know this Malati amount of selection
many places in the genomes we know also
them many many mutations are neutral and
we're not so concerned about whether the
neutral hypothesis is right or wrong as
sources we're interested in
understanding particular examples of how
selection works so I think nobody would
say I you might find some people that
say well the neutral hypothesis was
right or something like that
most Britannic variation is neutral but
I think most population geneticists
probably don't think like that today all
right they're all population does this
in the audience second tell me
Chipping with their opinions about the
status of the field but I think it's not
a small historical perspective I don't
think anybody really said it up eyelids
selection or neutrality but
degree so that perhaps that's I don't
know I'm not an expert on that I'll
trust you
alright so anyway so you can you can
it's the first approximation you can
look at background selection effect of
these two the weak utility rotations
segregating in the population as being a
production effective population size but
then also will reduce the amount of
genetic variability that you see turns
out that's also what a bit effect on a
dual frequencies and so on but at least
you can the strongest effect will be on
this affected population size and you
can see this reduction in variability
and you have can add recombination to
that so this is this is for a linked
neutral America that it's neutral linked
to a region in which mutations occur at
this rate without recombination and you
can develop similar expressions where
you have a point in the genome and then
you have recombination to all the points
in the genome and then you can look at
what's the reduction and variability
that you would expect under a model like
that so so this model makes the same
protection as a model before the more
recombination is the stronger and effect
you'll see of the the background
selection and you will see the less
effectively of the background selection
and you would see then because of that
also called positive correlation between
nucleotide diversity and and
recombination okay we take the models
also you can fill it to data so here
some from a paper by Kaplan Hudson where
they take this model of background
selection and they fit it to a
particular position in the genome using
various selection coefficients and some
information about recombination rates in
the genome okay so much of this has been
going on for many many years now
discussion about what are the factors
that determine the neck variability in
the population most of the time now as I
was saying people more interested in
luminous specific instances of natural
selection trying to understand that and
this sort of egg jungle out there of
different Mallis ad hoc methods for
trying to detect selection and why is
that well in part because really you
know as a full life
where you calculate the joint
probability for many low many its
positions in the genome and try to make
test of whether she fit different models
and see if selection is acting in the
particular position they're very very
difficult to come by
I mean computationally because of this
problem with the coalescence process as
a described before I'm modeling the
coalescence process with selection
it's these ones like that are really
intractable so instead most of the time
what we have is this variety of
different tests that people are trying
to look at one feature of the data
another to see is that compatible with a
neutral model or two we need to invoke
selection to be able to explain our data
and one way to think about it is that
you can have different forms of
selection they'll make different
predictions of different types of the
data so for example if you have a
selector sweep that would leave and lead
it to a decrease in interspecific
variability so population deck
variability but if you look at
variability between species it won't
lead to a reduction in that so you would
expect if there have been many mutations
that goes to fixation you will see an
increase in the rate of substitution
that is accumulation of differences
between species but as they go to a
fixation within species they'll be a
reduction in variables okay so people
looking at interested in provinces like
that to try to detect areas in the
genome that are on the selection and
again one of the things that as I
mentioned before that people are using
one of the tools is this degeneracy of
the genetic code that we have 64
possible triplets for only 20 amino
acids
go ahead intron that's published during
variant variability so within a species
so we take now we are all from the same
species or become here DNA sequence
between us we've compared you to a
chimpanzee that would be intraspecific
between species variability so probe
lacing the neck versus sometimes also
called comparative that's comparisons
between different species so one of the
things that people have been taking
greater lines off to the take selects in
many different ways again this is the
jealousy of the genetic code so same
logic as before if the selection it
should mostly react at the protein level
so we can
comparisons between these nonsynonymous
and tsunamis notations to say something
about Willis addictions acting and much
of the literature at least you know
until 10 years ago that we're I think
where people were successful in really
pinpointing positive selection that is
selection that is favored and new
mutation so it's increased in frequency
was really based on not so much
population genetic data but comparing
different species so the inter specific
variability by comparing different
species and the basic logic people are
using you can also use the same logic
within species just have more power
between species is your you'll get
accumulation of mutations of these two
types of notations nonsynonymous and
tsunamis limitations and you ask the
question are the more nonsense mutations
than you would expect given the
information of god from some anomalous
rotations about mutation rates so is
there any evidence that selection is
favored accumulation of nonsense
mutations alright and so people look at
these T and D s ratio in a moment I will
define more rigorously what at the NTS
ratio is this is the way that most
biologists think about the NTAs ratio so
I'll go through that first but then they
find a little bit more precisely in a
moment so if you this process you just
have a little bit of patience so this is
the way that most of the time you'll see
it explained explained there this TNTs
ratio you counts numbers nonsense
mutations between species and on
rotations between species they also
count the number of sites in which a
mutation would result in a nonsynonymous
change or synonymous change and then you
can get a ratio or a number of nonzero
substitutions
per nonsan on the site and number
synonymous substitutions person on this
time and it did is that if there was no
selection acting at the protein level if
it doesn't matter which amino acid you
have these two should be identical to
each other so this D and D s ratio which
also is called Omega that's the same as
at the MCA say the NTS ratio that should
be equal to 1 so that's neutrality of
selectively neutral to no selection if
selection is acting against new amino
acid mutations so that the go to
fixation at a lower rate than what you
would expect for neutral mutation then
Omega should be less than 1 and if
they're favored by natural selection so
that goes through fixation at a rate
that's
higher than what you expect for neutral
notation and we talk about positive
selection so you hear these words
negative selection positive selection a
lot originally I think they are defined
in terms of your finger a2 allele model
that something is selected negatively or
positively right well it's favorite or
not favorite in these models
it's then been translated into that
positive selection means that you have
an increase in the rate of substitution
about that that you would expect from a
neutral mutations and negative selection
is in the opposite okay so this whole
thing you know they're normal problems
with the way I presented this most of
all that this knows a string for example
as a synonymous site okay because if you
go back and look at the genetic code you
have things like this you know you have
you know if you look at the third
position here if you have a change from
a C to an a you change the amino acid
but C to you you don't change the amino
acid okay so the site of the source is
not synonymous and nonsynonymous it's
some fraction there off and so on so
that lots of papers in the early 90s on
oh how can we reject this how can we
take that into account I think people in
where people end up doing instead of
saying okay we can define it in a
different way
in terms of thinking of the substitution
process as a Markov chain with state
based on the six degrees one possible
since codons so free codons free
Triplets of nucleotides code for stop
codons so they're not allowed the 61
left sitting 61 Triplets of nucleotides
now you can set up a Markov chain one
category now you could imagine that you
know most nuts and on substitutions are
bad but you know there's a good one
there that will have Santa another guy
and that's in fact something that people
do model bats so you can model and you
can put in at this there's a
distribution of different DNA's racers
in different sites for example and you
can also that that depend on where
you're in the protein structure and so
on there's lots of models like that
alright so anyway so you define this
Markov process on this state
space on the 61 possible sense code on
this and then you have transition rates
in that macro model as follows this is a
similar model in many other models but
it's sort of the simplest type of model
people use you will hear you divide
between transitions and transversions
these are two different types of
mutations it doesn't really matter in
this but rates are proportional to the
stationary frequency of that current
okay so a codon is a triplet that's - in
this macro model is in a coding model
there's a stationary distribution you
have stationary probabilities of each
triplet of each : and you mutate from
state I to state J proportional to the
frequency or probability of being in
state J the marginal probability and
then you have a something that modifies
the rate depending on whether it's
nonsense or synonymous so if you have a
nonsense mutation you multiply it by
this rate modifier Omega here so that's
the TNTs ratio for perform so now that's
why things might make a little bit more
sense if we make is equal to one the
stuffing that distinguish turns nice and
soon on rotations right there's nothing
that's going on the protein level but if
selection works against new changes
Omega will be less than one if it works
in favor of new changes Omega will be
larger than one okay and now we can
space by heart policies about Omega and
you do things like allowing Omega to
vary among different scientific
different categories and in particular
you can ask the question are there any
evidence of any sites any positions in
the genome or the the genes were looking
at where Omega is larger than one where
there has been positive selection and
that's been used many many many times to
look at selection so for example in
viruses this is a this is the viral
particle remember a virus is sort of a
dull a little particle that has just
capsulated some RNA or DNA inside of it
that it will inject into the host cell
okay so it's not really living organism
in this thing that's not a real cell but
this is this is a mild particle from
inferred from the influenza virus that's
attached to a host cell on the surface
of that viral particle you have these
little pegs here that's a molecule
called him
and what our immune system reacts to is
that molecule primarily so our immune
system will recognize the muchif that it
sees in that protein and the reason why
we get influenza you know epidemics
again and again and again and again is
that that protein evolves very very fast
so we evolve we gain resistance to one
version of it but then this molecule
will mutate and it'll be positive
selection then they'll do positive
selection in that molecule so this is a
control of that molecule so this is like
one little peg here that's been blown up
and it's consumed like this and these
are residues particular positions in the
protein where there's a particular
height where this strongly statistically
significant evidence for at the NTS
ratio a value Omega that's larger than 1
that is positions where there's such a
high turnover allele it can't be
explained by just genetic drift and
mutation so selection must have favorite
change in those positions that happens
to also be positions where exponentially
you can show that they can be target for
the human immune system that they're a
bit hopes for that ok so that's an
example of how these methods have been
used I have some are like samples are
not really sure if I wanna go through
them anyway let's just do a little bit
about human evolution
you can you do the same thing humans so
we divert about five six million years
ago from chimpanzees and you can ask
what are the positions in the human
genome where there's a lot of selection
acting there and if you do that you'll
find that's and that's what people have
been finding again and again I came in
looking in many different species that
the genes that show most evidence of
this type of positive selection that
where the most residues are seem to be
targeted by positive selection favoring
change is genes that are highly
expressed in have function will in two
immunity in defense and particular
t-cell mediated immunity
what's the reason for that well those
are the genes that responds to these
changing viruses and all pathogens and
so they like the pathogenic environment
change all the time
so does our immune system in response to
that
yeah the unclassified biological process
this is an old slide they have fewer of
them that are unclassified now this is
back from 2005 so all right so so that
is you know one way that people used to
take selection by comparing different
species in terms of the population
genetic variation as a mansion there's a
host of different possible tests this is
one of the most popular one and famous
one test called the McDonnell Kreitman
tests spaced on the same principle the
right mutations between synonymous and
nonsynonymous Asians but then you don't
just look between species you also look
within species and then you can show
quite easily very similar argument that
under new trials in expectation the
ratio of A to B through equals the ratio
of C to D that is the ratio are willing
to between species variability if you
count number of mutations to be the same
for nuns nuns and pseudonymous rotations
that's quite easy to show and then you
can simply test if that is true by using
a test of homogeneity chi-square to
historic details to fish assess accessed
or something like that and even tested
these ratios in fact are equal to each
other
pila be doing that to a great extent in
many different species you can also use
the horse and ran of field models of soy
and Horrell that we talked about before
and then you can predict what would be
that where they expected values in these
categories and then you can make
something model based if you believe in
those models where you can then estimate
selection coefficients and this is an
example that's a map of selection in the
human genome where everything that's in
red that's where this negative selection
acting so selections acting on
segregating mutations that are
negatively selected and the blue ones is
where there's evidence for positive
selection and again this is this is also
back from 2005 six I think if you did
today we're much more data much more
complete data you would probably fill in
with many more low side than this ok so
here's a knowledge test this is in fact
the first test that was developed on
nucleotide to deal with nucleotide a DNA
sequence data and this it turns out
still to be a tremendously powerful test
actually compared to many other
participant develop subsequently this
test still has a lot of power on a mini
estate sense that you're interested in
and the logic is a little bit the same
as before you have now vocabulary the
usage change the ticketing sites its
variability within species you could
count the number of mutations observed
within species fix differences that's
the number of differences you'll serve
between species and now instead of
comparing non stands and non rotations
you compare put different positions in
the genome here I have two low sign in
in the genome but it could be no you
could you know dice and slice the genome
any way you want and as before you would
expect the ratio of segregating size to
fix differences to be the same for low
side you can show that if there's no
selection
you really expect an expectation that
should be true and then you can define a
finding a chi-square statistic that
trying to ask you could get the expected
values in a table like this and a 2 by K
table of low SCI and these two
categories get the expected number in
each category if you get approximation
of variance defined and statistic and
then ask if the value of that statistic
is so extreme that you can reject the
null hypothesis that the ratio of the
same so why are you doing something
different here now I'm not doing this is
something to get the distribution of the
statistic she needs simulations and the
reason why this is different from the
case before there you could do a normal
test of homogeneity you can't do that
here and that's because that is a
correlation a correlation between the
secretary sites within a locus okay that
correlation it says you do to the shared
core lessons tree between the different
sites in that locus
so that means that you wouldn't expect
given s 1 plus s 2 s 1 is not my normal
is this to be really normal if you do it
did it for the McDowell Kreitman test it
actually turns out that logic work there
because new students and national
science they share the same dean tree
the same genealogy they have it's in
coalescence free the interspersed among
each other but different those I here
have different
collisions trees so here you cannot
simply do a mistake the null hypothesis
here is that the ratio of segregating to
fix differences they expected number of
sick again to fix differences it's the
same for low sorry so that the ratio is
constant so that's perhaps perhaps the
most common of trial to test competing
with one or two other ones and the first
one on DNA sequence data and still
surprisingly powerful and of course
where does the power come from if you
have I'm just gonna finish that on take
your question if there's been a
selective sweep it will reduce this
number segregating sites if you have
lots of you know fast evolving genes pot
favorite by positive selection there are
increased number of fixed differences so
that kind of selection will change this
ratio or segregating to fix differences
okay so sick of getting means that if
you had take us as a population and then
I look at the positions in which we
differ from each other count how many
there are position like that that's the
number of second sites okay fix
differences those are differences if we
take a population of us and a population
of chimpanzees and ask what's the
difference between those so the fixed
these are you know ultimately you want
to set it up so these are multiple
exclusive you can't be in this set and
also next exactly the problem is that
it's very dependent upon the size of the
sample oh yeah me too this context which
may be useful for small samples
they're pretty lousy for big samples
because it's a huge amount of
information where is this right now
oh yeah no okay so that's it there's
another issue here about like from our
information and sample sizes I think in
any case this clearing user with
anything ever talked about so far the
front way a lot of information issue
earlier with the sample sizes is the
fact that you know you could have some
shared polymorphism that it's not fixed
for example and that the kind of
relation of what is segregating versus
fixed will depend on your sample size
and so there's some issues between that
and I swept under the carpet but this is
so usually the way this is done when
people actually apply the test they take
a sample from one population and find
all just count how much it's segregating
in that population and then they
compared to a reference other species so
for example humans chimpanzees and then
there's so many differences
yeah there's a great way that I think
from very little data even bigger
problem because there you have such the
sparsity of information you really want
to get all the information out of it now
we have such huge data sets we can
better afford to throw out some of the
information
so that's why this tremendous amount of
research in how to do that better but
many of the new tests that have been
proposed in fact on a ministers perform
worse than this this still tests that
beats many published tests if you
simulate the power so for example if you
take this test and compared to many of
the haplotype based statistic for
detecting selection and the most
parameter values this actually does
better than it was to those tests no
this could be applied any way you slice
a Tyson yeah a nice last one yeah so
that's the substance adventuresome means
by working well all right so one one
definition of working well is that you
get something which is more
statistically significant but if you
actually look at the plots of the data
they're all over the place you wouldn't
guess this is obviously there the other
one is if you have you know two models
one null model for another model and you
look at the data and they clearly
different from water looks better with
the other independent of whether you can
do some you know official single test
right and somehow I think those that you
have to then they get confused yeah to
avoid confusion in the way this is
formulated is that you have a neutral
null hypothesis you're trying to see if
we can reject that it's pretty specific
in that sense it's not maybe it's not
formulated as a model choice problem
anything women so barb I think maybe
what you're saying is that people ask
different questions okay
you using the extra data that you get I
mean you can go for something from
something that has an ROC of like
basically your power to detect positive
selection is like 50% at a reasonable
false positive rate you and once you
start pulling information across the
gene you just do a simple mixed effects
model you get like 99% power so having
more data really can't help yes
certainly yeah yeah I mean not best only
it can help it doesn't it does I mean it
well I mean I guess I making an argument
that this is not optimal because I don't
think anybody would ever claim its
optimal I'm just saying that this is
what I'm testing has been used and
compared to many other tests it has
smaller statistical power for you know
to reject the specific hypothesis people
interested in whether their interest
rate by neutral null hypothesis now I
don't wait here it's not this is optimal
in that you should go back and do that I
okay tell I will give you a test that
even works but it more useful and
perhaps you ought to like this illness
this is prime is the the most used test
if any this is the chattiness t-test
what that does is now we're using only
variation within a population and we
want to look if the distribution of
allele frequencies are compatible with
what we would expect from the neutral
expectation and instead of an aversive
always have to come used very simple
estimators of the population genetic
parameter theta which is equal to four
times the population size times the
mutation rate none of these is none of
these estimators are based on sufficient
statistics that they're not they're
extracting the estimators and they're
not sufficient sufficient but here we
have one that's based on the number
segregating sites s here is the number
of mutation like you see in the
population that's water since estimator
here's another one that's based on the
average number of pairwise differences
that's what we call pi before okay so
these are two different estimators
ensure that both under this standardized
function set both on
- estimators so what's a dreamer suggest
is using as a test - to use when you see
difference between the values from those
two estimators and use that as a
statistical test why would you do that
well this one just count the number of
sites this one actually uses information
about allele frequencies so this
particular statistic here if the
selection this is less affected than
this statistic here so if this negative
selection for example you have more
rotation so no little frequency positive
selection or higher your frequency and
we get a different distribution if this
Lexus sweeps all that can be captured to
a certain degree by this statistic where
it's just simply the difference between
these two estimates divided by an
expression for the variance in the
square root of the variance in the
distance derived under the hypothesis of
no recombination okay so that's the most
common new statistical perhaps you know
it's using a bit of information about
real frequency is that the other tests
don't use but generally doesn't have
very much power compared to many other
tests that people have develops say the
very very few Sorel principal tests that
have been developed one was developed
originally by Wolfgang Stephen no snakes
and no recombination I mean that no
solution and over this variance yet
divide that expression to write under no
recombination you can also rely on a pre
recombination under it becomes hot if
there is some recombination to get at
this expression it depends on the
expected the expectation of the total
tree length and truce two sites which we
don't really have simple expressions for
so this is all this is an assumption is
you're really rejecting a very composite
null hypothesis that has no selection it
has in its various assumption depending
on how you've done it on
recombination it's certainly a lot of
something about demography
so therefore people have I've been quite
wearing I've talked a little bit about
the effect of democracy later on but
peel has certainly been very skeptical
about the use of that in the eve use of
that but it's used all the time for
people for example scanning at genome
doing at what's the value of TT masti
and finding the place in the genome
where its most extreme and so on
all right so no stick towards more
principled methods that are still are
not full likelihood methods but these
are methods that calculate the light
loads in one science under hypothesis
about this business latest we've another
side chains account selection
coefficients free combinations on can
make a likelihood ratio relating through
the hypothesis of selection versus no
selection applicable to one side and
then form a composite light load by
taking the products of these marginal
likelet's along the sequence okay so
there's a lot of you know tradition in
statistics for forming estimators like
this when it's happy it's you can't make
a fool accurate approach so the sort of
theory of estimation estimation
equations that look at estimators are
not full likely estimators and also and
a growing theory on composite likely to
make methods that are formed like this
and what booth can did together with his
student at that point was that they took
publishing their models like the one we
were talking about and then get the
predictions of what you would see in a
site that's linked to a science right
that's been on the selection and also
get predictions of the distribution if
there hadn't been selection and use that
to form this composite like a ratio and
I worked in a different version that
does things like differently in the
slightest for that but maybe the main
main thing here is this that you can
derive these proverb logical
probabilities for each locus take the
product of them along the sequence to
form these composite like ulis now you
induce more of the information now
because you use information about allele
frequencies and the spatial pattern in
the genome of allele frequencies but
really good for locating where was their
selective sweep
these methods but it's still not a full
light load method and the reason why
it's not is it's very hard to compute
where this is very easy to compute so
back to the issue about democracy the
assumptions about the distribution of
allele frequencies depends heavily on
democracy so for example here you have
this statistic city masti on a model in
which this is a standard neutral model
that's the black Paris there and then
the model where the this population you
are sample from exchange migrants with
some other population and a rate of 1
micron every 10 keep generations and
then you get the distribution you can
see it has much bigger tails both
negative and positive values and so you
would tend to get a large amount of
false positives if you thought that this
was the correct null distribution but
really there has been migrant with
another population and of course real
populations there are always these kind
of complexities meaning that nobody
really believes these days that if you
take at to the MSD test and reject and
null hypothesis based on this
distribution here that that meaning
means has been selection but it
nonetheless is informative of the degree
of differences in allele frequencies
between this model and what you actually
see and that's the interpretation of
that today ok I only have a few more
minutes left is that right I wanted to
talk much more just mention one other
approach that people have been using for
detecting selection and in particular
when people are interested in selection
that's currently acting most of the time
I'm talking about selection and sensor
that there's been suite and so that you
had an advantageous rotation at the
frozen of population and then went to
fixation treats a frequency of hundred
percent of one in the population but
often you're even more interested in
figuring out any selection that's acting
right now okay so for example Truman
population is any strong selection and
acting right down the deal that's
spreading in the population and what
people don't use to look at that is that
they saw the intuition behind what's
being done is that if you have another
deal like that it says spreading the
population so it hasn't reached high
frequency there will be this class of
habit
types the whole model is identical then
I'm recently increased in frequency
because they all carry that advantageous
rotation and there will be a lower class
of hammer size that have the amount of
variability you would expect to see if
there has been no selected school so you
can look at the mount you can look for
mutations for which is true that those
mutations aren't very long HEPA types
will that identical to each other as
compared to the other Lilly class where
there's not a lot of what's called
haplotype famosa casa t so identical
haplotypes like this let's appear
pattern that people looking for and
there are a couple of different ways
that it's often that's a couple of
different tests that takes advantage of
that pattern and the kind of thing that
they're looking for is something like
this here you take in a particular
genome in the particular position and if
you know where your fingers been
selection look at two alleles
okay one that's associated with the red
color one that's associated with a blue
color every time you take the longest
the pair of haplotypes that i have the
longest amount of haplotype
identity between them and make that a
reference haplotype for the red one and
for the blue one and then you ask what's
the amount of shared identity along the
genome with these two times so what you
see is that there's a red type here with
lots of long habitat share identity and
the blue type not so much long not so
much many long tracts of shared identity
the pattern that you would expect if
there's ongoing selection so this is
from one of the most famous cases of
selection humans you know they'll say
Chia lactase locals that has to do with
evolution of lactase persistence the
fact that you can digest milk as adult
that you're not lactose intolerant where
they've been large amount of selection
until in European populations for a
particular variant that gives you that
like lactase persistence and it's linked
to this the breast haplotype here okay
so I think I'm gonna have to run out of
time I think I wasn't gonna stop stop
there and then maybe instead have some
time for questions and discussion
I mean I think it shows force about to
certain degree if you think that the
single strength don't apply in the amino
acids changing positions right so this
is so this is on a certain constraint at
the nucleotide level that exists but
that's also you know if the question is
so how much of that goes out in the wash
if it also applies to amino acid
changing mutations and I think that know
what is the element I'm you know I'm
sorry I've been including a lot of this
with these sub TNTs ratios and so but I
think that you know you should always
take into a little bit of grain of salt
please rate you know that a lot of
things that can affect these ratios I
think the most important thing even more
important that I think are the fact that
most data has some alignment in US and
that really affect these basic kind of
things a lot so for example number of
scans trying to take selection that we
published where it turns out you know
you you shift the line but a little bit
and then a third position become a
second position so all your synonymous
tastes you take some our nonsynonymous
then normal papers where I have primes
wonderful snakes in this thing and
netting because of this caviar so I
think a lot of thing bring any type of
in its handler to make an inference
purely by automatically about selection
like this I think there are problems
with all these different approaches and
I think we want simply want to if you
really want to believe that there's
something important function behind you
also want to then you'll get some of the
functional information just a public
service announcement like it's not just
the alignment issue but the sequence
that you align so with a lot of these
tests you're you're picking out or
following its genes across species and
like princess if you download things
like data from UCSC because that's
convenient that those aren't meant for
that that's not meant for deaf identify
my father's gene there's a whole genome
alignment that they subset later so
there's a decent chance that the gene
that you are aligning it's not related
at all someone that you're interested in
look at that so I'm like a general
comment made part of the difficulty it
seems is you know what questions is one
trying to get it all right I mean
somehow the neutral theory and he's the
neutral theory right or wrong always
seem to complete non sequitur I mean of
course it's wrong on long timescales it
might be right on short timescales all
right so then once not having to talk
about timescales or which aspects one is
talking about it how stronger its
effects are and then one of getting the
quantitative thing is I'm not trying to
reject neglect now let policies and so
on one is trying to say okay one is more
picture of the dynamics of what's going
on and he's trying to infer things from
that although things about that Jeff one
goes to the notes of opposite regimes
from humans and look to pathogens the
HIV or flu or looks at the bar
generation right and then you start
looking at some of the simple systems
and you see if you look at your freak if
they may not look that different but as
soon as you start looking distributions
and things which are and predictions all
over this data you find it completely
different that may not be so nice this
tickle test it'll give you a p-value for
it but there are you know Nova's the
facts but then one is trying to
distinguish between various definite
scenarios that involve some
understanding of the underlying
hopes maybe this workshop this is kind
of so they're going to move towards more
of a of a wider range of questions and I
think historically yeah I mean I don't
think I disagree I mean I think much
focus has been on how to can you detect
the husband selection right I mean
that's been oh how the problem was
funneling has it been selection not and
how do best detect that and idea created
that we need to want to bet honest a
hard selection action
and there's been selection I mean I
think you know so we agree on that but I
think if you go to a meeting with a blue
cheval it should find a lot of people
that say well if I look at the netic
variation within a species then the vast
majority of genes that are seen in grass
majority of parables yes there's no
selection on any of that and it's not
being affected really by selection
anyway I think you'll find a very large
proportion of your level agree with that
statement so an FIR then for them it'll
be you know still very important to show
that it's been any selects at all I I
think that that question is not
interesting anymore what I think you
still find some people that say that so
I don't know what some of the other
people that have go to these biology
meetings what you're thinking is that
right
you know you're also some mortar
selection that's pretty much true and
then we have to consider also
alternative explanations a lot to
selection and I've also I mean I'm also
someone who's interested in instances of
selection but I think it's a quite a
hard problem let's have a different
viewpoint okay now I need to work in the
software as well right I mean it might
be good I mean yeah just awfully I think
the conclusion Alice from recent papers
that it's just all selection like we've
had really the little models we have
really understand it anymore I think
that's what most of the recent papers on
Drosophila is pointing towards I think
humans so there's a debate is do we not
see in humans because we're not living
the right way humans for an immensely
different because we're low effects of
police and science for example and I
think it may be I know and that the same
team on that but I think that some
people would disagree with that and
think that you mean shewing is this
possible selection that we're and we
have previously appreciated so the
difference of opinions about that so I
figure I guess it's there's still you
know some debate about that but I think
it's over the theory I would agree that
really what we need to understand well
don't have I figured really really good
methods for understanding you know if we
have some data relating that to
different models of selection and how
selections operate and really understand
then it was looking at the humans or so
Fleur whom these questions okay whatever
selection is primarily going on
individual genes or is almost I mean I
think that to some of the problem is
that there's so much selection nearby
genes and you don't see the section on
each gene right I mean that's that's
what it is time to think there so that
you know these balls where we just you
know we use the rest a song as soon as
neutral and Louie one team is that
different from the rest and so on that
has misled us into software to we do not
realize how much selection of alleles at
least I know number to select in
assistive believe that these days
because they because of linkage right
look you generally see a narrow stasis
all right
thank you very much